- Yaël Braun-Pivet: L'ordre du
jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par monsieur
Philippe Vigier pour le groupe
démocrate.
- Philippe Vigier: Ma question
s'adresse à Christophe Béchu.
Monsieur le ministre, entre le 27
juin et le 6 juillet, il y a eu de
très nombreuses dégradations et
des violences très fortes dans ce
pays.
Nous les avons quasiment
unanimement condamnées.
Je regrette que quelques amis de
monsieur Mélenchon ne l'aient pas
fait.
Ces violences faisaient suite à la
mort de ce jeune Nahel et elles
ont touché des symboles de la
République, des écoles, des
bibliothèques, des mairies, même
un bus médicalisé.
Ces violences sont inacceptables
parce qu'elles sont le fait de
certains qui veulent le chaos.
Il n'y a pas de place pour le
chaos.
Monsieur le ministre, j'ai été
indigné de voir que le week-end
dernier, des députés Insoumis
étaient présents lors d'une
manifestation interdite.
Lorsqu'on vote la loi en semaine,
on la respecte le week-end.
Monsieur le ministre, il s'agit
maintenant de reconstruire ces
symboles de la République, de
faire en sorte que ces bâtiments
publics, ces lieux d'accueil
soient capables de fonctionner
demain, que ce n'est pas
l'impuissance qui est au
rendez-vous, mais au contraire,
l'efficacité.
Que comptez-vous faire en matière
d'urbanisme pour simplifier les
procédures?
Monsieur le ministre, ce qui est
important, c'est de montrer que la
République est là, qu'elle ne
lâchera pas, qu'il n'y a pas de
place pour le chaos et que cette
République exige que chacun
respecte les lois et que chacun
aide celles et ceux qui sont en
première ligne et qui ont été
exemplaires.
J'attends vos réponses.
Merci, monsieur le ministre
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique de la
Cohésion des Territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Recevant les
maires de plusieurs centaines de
communes touchées par les
dégradations, par les incendies,
par les démolitions d'une partie
des bâtiments, le président de la
République a pris un engagement,
celui que nous puissions évoquer
un texte d'urgence pour accélérer
cette reconstruction.
Le Parlement sera soumis d'un
projet de loi d'habilitation sous
ordonnance qui sera présenté au
Conseil des ministres, qui
comprendra trois articles.
Un article pour accélérer sur
l'aménagement, un autre pour
faciliter les règles en termes de
commandes publiques et un autre
pour poser la question des
financements.
Sur la reconstruction, il faut
faire en sorte que dès qu'on fait
une déclaration préalable de
travaux, on puisse les commencer.
Il faut faire en sorte que la
reconstruction à l'identique
puisse se faire, même si
entre-temps, il y a eu une
modification des procédures.
Ensuite, en termes de commandes
publiques, il faut favoriser
jusqu'à 1 million d'euros, sans
publicité, mais avec comparaison
des offres, le fait de pouvoir
accélérer la commande de travaux
pour que la dizaine d'écoles qui
ont été incendiées par les
émeutiers puissent rouvrir dès la
rentrée.
Il faut supprimer la nécessité
qu'il y ait au moins 20% de restes
à charge pour les collectivités
pour pouvoir imaginer qu'entre les
assurances et les conseils
départementaux, on puisse aller
vers un reste à charge zéro.
Ce qui va se passer dans les
prochaines semaines, c'est
précisément un rendez-vous, un
rendez-vous pour faire en sorte
que nos condamnations quasi
unanimes de ces violences
s'accompagnent par les moyens
concrets de pouvoir permettre aux
maires de restaurer les services
publics le plus vite possible.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Julien Odoul pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Julien Odoul: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Des émeutes de Vaulx-en-Velin en
1990 à l'embrasement des banlieues
en 2005, tout le monde pouvait
prévoir ce qui allait se passer,
tout le monde sauf Emmanuel
Macron.
Même votre ami Gérard Collomb vous
avait averti avant son départ du
ministère de l'Intérieur en
déclarant que nous allions vivre
face-à-face.
Demain, c'est aujourd'hui, avec
près de 24.000 feux sur la voie
publique, près de 12.000 véhicules
incendiés, plus de 7000 policiers
et gendarmes blessés.
En Guyane, un homme innocent est
mort, tué sur son balcon par une
balle de 9 mm tirée par un
émeutier qui visait les policiers.
Je veux rendre hommage à cette
victime.
Alors que vous aviez promis 100
jours d'apaisement, les Français
ont subi cinq nuits de chaos et de
terreur.
Face à l'ampleur de ce
déchaînement de violence, votre
gouvernement a choisi de sortir
l'artillerie de carnaval et la
matraque de Guignol, avec la
rédaction d'un flyer à destination
des parents, ou encore
l'interdiction de la vente de
mortiers d'artifice pour le 14
juillet.
Les Français en ont assez de votre
déni de réalité et de votre
impuissance chroniques.
65% des Français demandent des
sanctions contre les parents de
multirécidivistes avec la
suspension des allocations.
Qu'attendez-vous pour agir?
69% des Français demandent la
suspension d'excuse de minorité
pour les mineurs qui participent
aux émeutes.
La majorité des Français
considèrent qu'il y a trop
d'immigrés en France.
Qu'attendez-vous pour agir?
Qu'attendez-vous pour écouter les
Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
Olivier Véran, porte-parole du
gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran: Monsieur le
député Julien Odoul, nous n'avons
pas attendu vos propos pour agir.
45.000 agents des forces de
l'ordre ont été déployés.
Par contre, monsieur le député,
vous n'attendez jamais pour
commenter, pour généraliser, pour
calomnier, pour faire de la petite
politique.
C'est à ça qu'on vous reconnaît.
Quand vous parlez de Guignol et de
carnaval en parlant des forces de
sécurité intérieure, en parlant
des pompiers, en parlant de toutes
les personnes qui se sont
déployées sur le territoire, qui
ont maintenu l'ordre dans les
quartiers nuit après nuit, en
évitant de faire des victimes
collatérales, monsieur le député,
exprimez-vous mieux!
Tout le monde a compris ici.
Votre réaction montre ce qu'il y a
derrière votre question.
Nous cherchons l'unité de la
nation.
Nous cherchons l'ordre et les
responsabilités.
Nous cherchons à sanctionner tous
ceux qui doivent l'être.
Nous parlons de responsabilité
parentale.
Nous avons raison d'en parler
parce que si nous ne le faisions
pas, nous passerions à côté d'un
problème sociétal grave.
Des enfants de 12 ans auraient pu
se balader avec des briquets et
des armes à la main pour aller
dégrader les bâtiments publics.
Nous voulons que la justice soit
rendue de manière efficace, y
compris le dimanche, avec des
dizaines de comparaisons
immédiates.
C'est l'exemple qui a été envoyé à
ces émeutiers.
Monsieur le député, nous nous
battons pour l'ordre.
Au fond, vous vous battez pour le
désordre parce que c'est votre
beurre et votre miel.
Les Français ne sont pas dupes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: monsieur
Julien Odoul?
- Julien Odoul: Quelle indigence!
Les Français n'attendent et
n'attendront rien de vous.
Vivement 2027!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jérôme Guedj pour le groupe
socialiste.
- Jérôme Guedj: Ma question
s'adresse à vous, madame la
Première ministre.
A en croire les journaux, et
certains de vos ministres, c'est
peut-être la dernière fois que
vous vous pliez à cet exercice des
questions au gouvernement.
A vrai dire, les Français s'en
fichent.
Ce n'est pas le casting qui
compte, mais le récit et les actes
que vous posez.
Nous les cherchons, en vain.
Après la désastreuse adoption au
forceps de la réforme des
retraites, vous avez bricolé avec
monsieur le président Macron les
100 jours.
Nous y voilà.
Pour quel résultat?
Vous voulez gagner du temps pour
vous-même, vous en avez fait
perdre au pays et aux Français.
Vous dites que vous avez délivré,
reprenant la novlangue managériale
de vos chers cabinets de conseil.
Vous avez délivré quoi, au juste,
qui change la vie des gens?
Vous promettiez aux Français 100
jours d'apaisement.
Vous les avez plongés un peu plus
dans l'épuisement.
Epuisement face à l'inflation et à
la crise du pouvoir d'achat.
Epuisement social, évidemment,
après la réforme des retraites.
Epuisement face à la crise des
services publics, de la police à
l'hôpital, où vous refusez de
questionner les moyens et les
méthodes d'intervention,
l'organisation, alors même que la
mort de Nahel devrait vous obliger
à repenser ces services publics.
Evidemment, épuisement de nos
ressources, de notre biodiversité,
de notre qualité de vie face à
l'inaction climatique.
Comme si cela ne suffisait pas,
vous avez ajouté un épuisement
démocratique: toujours plus de
verticalité et la promesse
enterrée de légiférer autrement,
refusant nos propositions
transpartisanes sur les déserts
médicaux, sur EDF ou sur le grand
âge.
A la place, il y a toujours plus
de 49.3!
La seule question qui vaille: pour
vous et surtout pour les Français,
y a-t-il une vie heureuse après
les 100 jours?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
Olivier Véran, porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre chargé du
Renouveau démocratique.
- Olivier Véran: Monsieur le
député Jérôme Guedj, j'ai envie de
dire cher Jérôme...
Il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui, il me
revient d'avoir de la mémoire pour
nous deux.
Il me revient de me souvenir des
temps où nous étions assis sur ce
banc en train de guetter cette
courbe du chômage qui n'en
finissait pas de ne pas
s'inverser.
Au bout des 100 jours, vous
demandez quels progrès pour les
Français?
Il y a plus de pouvoir d'achat et
des meilleurs emplois.
Monsieur le député, j'ai de la
mémoire pour nous deux.
Nous étions sur ces bancs!
La Première ministre vient
d'annoncer 7 milliards
supplémentaires dans le cadre de
la planification écologique.
Vous et moi...
Au fond, vous avez de la mémoire.
Vous et moi aurions salué ce type
d'annonce.
Vous parlez de l'hôpital.
Nous étions dans la même
commission.
Le budget annuel accordé à
l'hôpital était de 18 milliards de
moins que ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui, avec Emmanuel Macron.
Reconnaissez les progrès.
Je me souviens de discussions que
nous avions!
Que vous est-il arrivé, monsieur
Jérôme Guedj?
Rejoignez cette majorité.
Il n'est jamais trop tard.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Emilie
Chandler pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Emilie Chandler: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin, ministre de
l'Intérieur.
Depuis le 27 juin, notre pays a
connu des nuits de troubles et
d'affrontements.
Des nuits durant lesquelles nous
avons été nombreux sur les bancs
de cet hémicycle à appeler au
calme, au respect de la
République.
Durant ces nuits, les policiers,
les gendarmes les sapeurs-pompiers
se sont mobilisés et ont répondu
avec le plus grand
professionnalisme.
Un dévouement exemplaire face à
des situations tendues et
violentes.
Je tiens à saluer leur travail et
leur engagement.
Ils ont fait leur devoir pour
protéger les Français.
808 policiers et gendarmes ainsi
que 35 sapeurs-pompiers ont été
blessés.
Autant de blessures qui marqueront
nos forces de l'ordre et de
secours aussi sûrement que les
images de violence dont nous avons
été témoins.
Pourtant, au sein de notre
hémicycle, certains députés font
peu de cas du travail immense pour
ramener le calme dans nos rues.
Ces élus soufflent sur les braises
en participant à des
manifestations interdites par les
services de l'Etat, en écharpe
tricolore, quand certains chantent
en mémoire d'Adama Traoré...
A croire que nos collègues
cherchent à n'assumer aucune
responsabilité.
Ils cherchent à faire monter la
tension, à soutenir la violence.
C'est oublier les mairies
incendiées.
La vérité, c'est que des
mouvements d'ultragauche
instrumentalisent l'émotion
légitime que nous avons tous
ressentie.
Ma question est simple: comment le
gouvernement compte-t-il
concrétiser le soutien apporté à
nos forces de l'ordre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin, ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
députée, je crois que les Français
dans leur ensemble ont été
extrêmement choqués que des
parlementaires en écharpe puissent
défiler au son de "Tout le monde
déteste la police".
Je veux dire que ceux qui ont
défilé sur ce son, sans faire un
tweet, sans regretter, ne
déshonorent pas la police
nationale, mais déshonorent leur
mandat et la vie politique.
Alors, madame la députée, plutôt
que de donner publicité à des
extrémistes qui crachent sur la
tombe des policiers morts, je
voudrais ici faire applaudir tous
les policiers morts en service,
qui laissent des veuves et des
orphelins.
Gérald Darmanin énumère les
policiers morts sur le terrain.
- Vive la République et vive la
police nationale!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame...
S'il vous plaît!
S'il vous plaît, un peu de
silence!
La parole est à madame Marianne
Maximi pour La France Insoumise.
- Marianne Maximi: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre, mais avant
cela, monsieur
Gérald Darmanin, quelle honte vous
venez de nous faire!
Vous affirmez que nous serions
sortis de l'arc républicain.
Madame la Première ministre, que
reste-t-il de l'arc républicain?
Dès les législatives, vous l'avez
détruit quand vous avez appelé à
faire barrage contre nous!
Pourtant, au second tour de la
présidentielle, vous avez pu
compter sur les électeurs de
gauche, qui ont voté pour vous
contre l'extrême droite.
Ce jour-là, ils étaient
républicains.
Que s'est-il passé?
La réponse est simple: la NUPES a
mis votre parti en minorité.
Elle vous inquiète plus que 89
députés du Rassemblement National
car nous représentons une
alternative crédible à votre
politique, une rupture face au
libéralisme autoritaire.
Le Rassemblement National est une
arnaque sociale.
Il ne contestera jamais vos
mesures néolibérales.
Tout est bon pour fracturer la
NUPES!
Collègues, je vous pose la
question: est-ce antirépublicain
que de vouloir une police sans
racisme?
Dans ce cas-là, l'ONU est
antirépublicaine.
Vous nous donnez des leçons.
Qui détourne le Fonds Marianne?
Qui écrase le Parlement?
Qui se tait quand les syndicats de
police menacent de sédition?
Rien!
Attaquez les contre-pouvoirs,
interdire des manifestations
pacifiques, fracturer la société,
c'est ça, aimer la République!
A force de courir derrière
l'extrême droite, vous allez
tomber.
Le plus dur, ce n'est pas la
chute, mais l'atterrissage.
La République, ce n'est pas une
carte qu'on abat contre ces
oppositions.
La République, c'est la
souveraineté du peuple.
C'est celles et ceux qui veulent
la liberté, l'égalité, la
fraternité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran, porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre chargé du
Renouveau démocratique.
- Olivier Véran: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, madame la
députée Marianne Maximi, vous
posez cette question pour vous
faire passer pour des victimes.
Vous cherchez à vous faire passer
pour des victimes parce que vous
vous rendez compte que vous n'avez
pas été à la hauteur de la
situation.
Vous dites que la police tue.
Vous parlez d'une loi comme d'un
permis de tuer.
Vous affirmez que certains
bâtiments ne sont pas à détruire,
mais vous excluez d'autres
bâtiments.
Vous participez avec l'écharpe
tricolore républicaine autour du
cou à des manifestations
interdites par les préfets de la
République.
Vous vous rendez compte, madame la
députée, que vous n'avez pas été à
la hauteur?
Certains de vos partenaires sont
là pour vous le dire.
C'est trop facile, madame la
députée.
Les Français ne vous croient plus.
Si vous voulez rentrer dans le
champ républicain, respectez la
République.
Respectez votre mandat et
l'écharpe que vous portez.
Respectez les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Gosselin pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Philippe Gosselin: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
l'Education nationale.
Quel ministre êtes-vous donc?
Dans des dizaines de villes et
dans des villes moyennes alors
épargnées par les violences
urbaines, on a incendié plus de
2500 bâtiments publics.
Plus de 1000 commerces ont été
touchés.
Plus de 250 établissements
d'enseignement ont été touchés.
On ne vous a pas entendu.
Des intellectuels, des étudiants
dénoncent l'idéologie woke
et la cancel culture.
Le niveau de nos élèves recule.
Vous ne faites toujours rien.
Aucun de nos concitoyens n'a
vraiment entendu ce que vous
souhaitiez faire.
On vous entend très mal, monsieur
le ministre.
En revanche, vous démontrez tous
vos talents d'idéologue.
Vous vous placez en arbitre des
élégances de la pensée, souvent
unique.
Vous distribuez les bons et les
mauvais points.
Vous méprisez les journalistes et
les équipes et des millions de nos
concitoyens.
J'évoque ici la polémique de ce
week-end avec CNews et Europe 1.
Là, on vous entend vraiment trop.
Quid de la laïcité et du
harcèlement scolaire?
Là, on voudrait vraiment vous
entendre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Pap Ndiaye, ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
- Pap Ndiaye: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Philippe Gosselin, je vous
dirai un mot à propos des
questions scolaires.
Je suis d'ailleurs auditionné à
cet égard dans quelques heures.
Si vous avez un quelconque intérêt
pour ces questions, apparemment
pas, vous assisterez à l'audition.
Je vais vous répondre sur la
deuxième partie de votre propos.
Vous faites partie d'un groupe qui
a une tradition républicaine et
gaulliste et qui a longtemps
combattu l'extrême droite.
Je m'étonne donc que vous vous
étonniez des constats que je fais
sur l'évolution d'une chaîne de
télévision.
Il y a la liberté de la presse,
mais il y a aussi la liberté
d'expression.
Ce sont deux fondamentaux de la
démocratie.
Il ne s'agit de censurer ni l'une
ni l'autre.
Ma collègue Rima Abdul-Malak a
déjà rappelé ici les obligations
qui s'imposent aux chaînes à
travers la loi de 1986.
L'Arcom a mis en garde et mis en
demeure plus d'une vingtaine de
fois la chaîne de télévision que
vous mentionnez.
Je ne suis pas le seul à faire
constat.
Ai-je invité à boycotter?
Ai-je pointé du doigt tel
journaliste?
Non.
Je ne fais que commenter de
manière banale la ligne politique
d'une chaîne de télévision.
C'est mon droit le plus strict,
monsieur le député.
Je tiens à ce droit, comme vous
avez le droit de commenter ce que
j'ai pu dire lors d'une interview.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Monsieur
Philippe Gosselin?
Un peu de silence, s'il vous
plaît!
- Philippe Gosselin: On attend un
ministre pleinement concentré sur
ses fonctions gouvernementales,
pas de censeur et pas de
philosophe de bas étage.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Pap Ndiaye: Permettez-moi
simplement de vous répondre par
cette citation du président
Jacques Chirac en 2007: "Ne
composez jamais avec l'extrémisme,
le racisme, l'antisémitisme ou le
rejet de l'autre.
Tout dans l'âme de la France dit
non à l'extrémisme."
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
Applaudissements
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Isabelle Rauch.
- Isabelle Rauch: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Transition numérique.
Interpellé à quelques kilomètres
de chez moi, un jeune homme de 16
ans s'est exprimé ainsi sur les
réseaux sociaux, de manière
violente.
Il faisait sa révolution seul dans
sa chambre tandis que d'autres
passaient aux actes.
Dès qu'on regarde une vidéo, les
réseaux sociaux s'organisent pour
proposer des vidéos du même
acabit.
Toute la France s'est embrasée.
Dans notre bulle, on appelle à la
haine et à la vengeance.
Vous l'avez dit, les dynamiques de
viralité ont pu nourrir les
violences.
Au Sénat, certains ont révélé les
conclusions de leur mission
d'enquête sur TikTok.
Opacité sur l'algorithme, sur la
gouvernance, sur les liens avec
les puissances étrangères...
Les réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle
multiplicateur sur les actes et
les effets.
Au-delà de leurs responsabilités,
c'est leur fonctionnement qu'il
nous faut comprendre.
Si la coopération avec les géants
du numérique a été présentée comme
exemplaire, ce sont seulement
plusieurs centaines de retraits
immédiats qui ont été opérés.
Une approche indispensable, mais
pas suffisante.
Alors que nous nous apprêtons à
légiférer sur l'espace numérique,
c'est sur la connaissance et la
compétence de nos concitoyens, sur
le fonctionnement des outils
numériques que je souhaite vous
questionner.
Nous avons pris nos
responsabilités sur la majorité
numérique.
En complément et à la lumière des
événements récents, il est
indispensable d'agir sur trois
fronts.
La régulation en situation
d'urgence, la responsabilité
parentale numérique et la
pédagogie des réseaux et du
numérique en général.
Je souhaite connaître le chemin
que vous comptez emprunter.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
Jean-Noël Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, madame la
présidente, merci pour votre
question.
Quelques heures après le début des
émeutes, avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur, nous avons convoqué
les principales plates-formes de
réseaux sociaux pour les rappeler
à leur obligation devant la loi,
le retrait des contenus illicites
qui leur sont signalés et la
réponse prompte aux réquisitions
qui leur sont adressées.
Nous leur avons demandé par
ailleurs d'exercer la plus grande
vigilance sur les fonctionnalités
de leurs services susceptibles de
porter atteinte à la sécurité et à
l'ordre public.
Le résultat: des milliers de
contenus ont été retirés.
Des centaines de comptes ont été
supprimés.
Des dizaines de réquisitions ont
été traitées.
Le résultat, c'est que dans
l'Ille-et-Vilaine, dans le
Pas-de-Calais, en Haute-Savoie,
dans les Pyrénées-Atlantiques et
dans le Val-de-Marne, des
individus ont été condamnés à des
peines de prison pour s'être livré
sur Internet à des appels au
meurtre de policiers, de
gendarmes, aux menaces à des
maires ou vis-à-vis des
commissariats ou de gendarmerie.
Les obligations vont se durcir
pour les plates-formes de réseaux
sociaux avec l'entrée en vigueur
le 25 août prochain du règlement
sur les services numériques obtenu
l'année dernière.
Cela leur imposera de prendre
toutes les mesures pour éviter que
leurs services portent atteinte à
la sécurité publique.
Pour les auteurs, par exemple,
celles et ceux qui se livrent en
ligne à des faits de violence
pourraient être condamnés à une
peine de bannissement des réseaux
sociaux.
S'agissant des parents, vous
l'avez rappelé, la proposition de
loi qui est devenue loi permettra
d'activer la responsabilité
parentale.
Pour tirer tout le bilan des
événements tragiques que nous
avons connus, j'ai constitué un
groupe de travail transpartisan
qui se réunira dès demain pour
tirer les leçons de l'épisode que
nous avons vécu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Béatrice
Descamps.
- Béatrice Descamps: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur.
Les résultats du baccalauréat ont
été publiés.
La phase d'attribution des voeux
sur Parcoursup se termine.
De nombreux étudiants ont retenté
une candidature sur Parcoursup,
faute d'avoir obtenu une école
l'année précédente.
Les algorithmes de Parcoursup font
pourtant barrage au fil des années
à ces étudiants.
Une jeune étudiante de ma
circonscription rêve de devenir
orthoptiste.
Malgré de bons résultats et sans
explication, sa candidature à
l'issue de l'obtention du bac en
2020 ne lui avait pas permis
d'intégrer l'école.
Elle avait intégré une prépa, à
l'issue de laquelle elle a été
malheureusement déclassée sur
Parcoursup.
Elle rentre donc en BTS.
Après ce BTS, qu'elle a terminé
cette année, elle a reformulé sa
demande pour intégrer la formation
d'orthoptiste et se retrouve à
nouveau sur liste d'attente.
Elle n'a, semble-t-il, que très
peu de chances d'intégrer cette
formation l'an prochain.
Cette situation pose question:
comment une élève peut essuyer
autant de refus alors que son
profil en compétence est confirmé
chaque année?
Madame la ministre, je sais que
vous avez oeuvré pour une
amélioration progressive et une
meilleure transparence de la
plate-forme.
Dans quelle mesure Parcoursup
donne-t-il réellement sa chance
aux choix professionnels?
N'y aurait-il pas dans
l'algorithme de Parcoursup une
difficulté particulière qui
entraverait les chances de
réussite de certains élèves et
étudiants selon les écoles?
Que répondre à ces étudiants qui
m'interpellent?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Sylvie
Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Béatrice
Descamps, d'abord, merci pour
votre question précise qui permet
d'avoir des cas.
La phase d'admission Parcoursup
s'est terminée.
Pour vous donner un chiffre, c'est
9 lycéens sur 10 et plus de 8
élèves en réorientation sur 10.
C'est 1,8 point de plus que l'an
dernier.
Il faut avoir un oeil particulier
sur les étudiants en
réorientation.
Il n'y a rien qui bloque au niveau
de la plate-forme.
C'est au niveau des commissions
d'enseignement que les dossiers
sont regardés et rien ne bloque
particulièrement au niveau des
étudiants en réorientation.
Les équipes de Parcoursup, les
rectorats, restent mobilisés pour
cette deuxième phase
complémentaire.
Il reste 100.000 places sur 6300
formations et tous les étudiants,
lycéens ou étudiants en
réorientation, sont normalement
contactés par téléphone pour
regarder leur projet.
Ce que je peux conseiller, c'est
de se mettre sur les commissions
d'accès à l'enseignement supérieur
au niveau des rectorats, de
regarder leurs dossiers, et au
niveau des parcours.
Parcoursup est reconnue
aujourd'hui pour sa transparence.
Nous avons progressé aussi sur les
périodes de stress, puisque la
phase d'admission principale a
duré 37 jours cette année contre
108 en 2018.
Nous allons continuer à
accompagner et à améliorer
Parcoursup.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Thomas
Portes.
- Thomas Portes: Monsieur
Darmanin.
Samedi, à l'appel du comité Vérité
justice pour Adama, nous avons
fait une marche antiraciste.
En Macronie, on interdit les
marche antiracistes et on laisse
défiler les nazis.
Votre arc républicain n'est rien
d'autre qu'un arc réactionnaire.
Nous serons toujours aux côtés de
celles et ceux qui se mobilisent
contre les violences policières et
pour la République.
Ces violences, vous les niez, mais
elles existent et elles se
multiplient.
Elles ont des noms et des visages:
Cédric Chouviat, Adama Traoré,
Nahel et tant d'autres.
Ce sont les morts de vos
violences.
Depuis des mois, la BRAV-M sème la
terreur dans les rues du pays.
260.000 citoyens ont déjà demandé
sa dissolution.
Vous avez enterré la pétition avec
la complicité de l'extrême droite.
L'arc réactionnaire est au service
des violences policières.
Samedi, la BRAV-M a montré son
nouveau visage: une brigade
violente, hors de contrôle,
antirépublicaine, une brigade qui
a cassé le dispositif d'évacuation
de la manifestation mis en place
par leurs propres collègues.
Trouvez-vous normal que des
journalistes soient frappés et
jetés au sol?
Trouvez-vous normal qu'un CRS ait
dû s'interposer pour protéger les
manifestants de la BRAV-M?
La préfecture ne leur a pas donné
l'ordre d'intervenir.
Qui a donné l'ordre à la BRAV-M
d'être là à la fin de la
manifestation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci pour la
parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin en: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur le député
Thomas Portes.
Vous auriez peut-être dû commencer
par le commencement.
La manifestation a été interdite
par un préfet de la République et
son interdiction a été validée par
la justice administrative.
Vous avez souhaité...
Quand je dis "vous", ce sont les
organisateurs, mais vous les avez
largement soutenus.
Vous avez voulu organiser une
contre-manifestation place de la
République.
Le préfet de police a pris une
nouvelle interdiction de
manifester et vous ne l'avez pas
contestée.
Trouvez-vous normal que des
parlementaires, élus par la nation
bravent des décisions
préfectorales et des décisions de
justice?
Trouvez-vous normal d'être parmi
une foule qui crie "tout le monde
déteste la police"?
Trouvez-vous normal que l'on s'en
prenne physiquement aux forces de
l'ordre?
Ce sont sur ces bases que des
personnes ont été interpellés,
notamment le frère de madame
Traoré.
Vous feriez partie de l'arc
républicain si vous défendiez ceux
qui tous les jours défendent la
République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Thomas Portes: Aucune réponse.
Vous n'êtes pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur.
Vous êtes le ministre des
violences policières, soumis à la
BRAV-M.
Nous demandons sa dissolution!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Emmanuel Pellerin...
Ah, monsieur le ministre?
Excusez-moi.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, tout ce qui est excessif
est insignifiant...
Huées
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
silence!
- Gérald Darmanin: Vous dites des
contrevérités.
Je vous encourage, comme l'a fait
un sénateur de la NUPES, de venir
passer quelques heures avec des
policiers.
Soyez parmi eux, touchez leur
salaire, risquez votre vie,
embrasser une dernière fois vos
enfants et alors vous aurez à
faire des gestes.
Il est facile de parler dans un
fauteuil rouge, il est plus
compliqué d'aller voir les
policiers en face!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Applaudissements
La parole est à monsieur Emmanuel
Pellerin.
- Emmanuel Pellerin: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Olivier Klein, ministre chargé de
la Ville et du Logement.
Monsieur le ministre, ils en
veulent aux institutions, à tout
le monde.
C'est ce que m'a dit un médiateur
social de ma commune de
Boulogne-Billancourt.
A Meudon-la-Forêt, le commissariat
a été incendié.
Les forces de police étaient en
sous-effectif.
Pour autant, ma circonscription ne
s'est pas embrasée grâce à cinq
médiateurs référents et près de 90
agents municipaux déployés pour
les circonstances par le maire,
dont je salue ici le courage.
Si elles ont mis en exergue des
violences et des tensions sociales
aiguës, ces émeutes ont aussi eu
pour avantage de mettre en lumière
le rôle fondamental joué par les
médiateurs sociaux.
Mis en place par le maire de
Boulogne-Billancourt, ces
médiateurs assurent au quotidien
la tranquillité publique et
l'apaisement des situations les
plus conflictuelles.
Ces agents, très implantés et
sectorisés, ont comme dénominateur
commun d'être issus des quartiers
en cause et de représenter une
figure d'autorité.
Ils ont permis d'apaiser les
tensions, de circonscrire des
incendies et d'éviter des
pillages.
Je salue mon collègue Patrick
Vignal qui a déposé une
proposition de loi visant à
reconnaître les médiateurs pour ce
qu'ils sont: de vrais
professionnels de la relation.
Reconstructeurs d'un lien social
disparu dans les quartiers
prioritaires, ils reconnectent les
jeunes aux institutions sociales.
Face à ce constat, comment le
gouvernement compte-t-il agir afin
d'encourager la Ville à soutenir
l'intervention des médiateurs
sociaux et à favoriser de vrais
circuits courts et transparents
entre l'éducation, la justice, la
police et les collectivités?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Emmanuel
Pellerin.
Je vous remercie chaleureusement
de votre question qui me permet de
mettre en lumière le travail très
important mené au quotidien par
les adultes en général, par les
militants associatifs et par les
médiateurs dans les villes et les
quartiers populaires.
Ca me permet de leur adresser
toute notre reconnaissance, aux
médiateurs, médiateurs municipaux,
auprès des 5000 adultes-relais,
auprès des 600 personnes qui
travaillent dans la médiation de
la prévention et qui jouent un
rôle important dans nos quartiers
et qui ont joué un rôle important
dans l'objectif qui était le
nôtre, celui du retour au calme,
du retour à l'ordre dans nos
quartiers populaires auprès des
forces de police, des élus et des
adultes.
Dans un moment comme celui-là,
c'est le temps des adultes et
l'ensemble de ceux qui ont
contribué à jouer un rôle
important.
Comme vous, je crois au rôle
fondamental de ce métier si
important dans la politique de la
Ville, celui de médiateur.
Je salue aussi la réflexion menée
par le député Patrick Vignal sur
ce métier qui joue un rôle très
important dans différents
domaines, celui de l'école, celui
de l'accès aux soins, celui de la
lutte contre le décrochage et la
fracture numérique.
Beaucoup de médiateurs ont été mis
en place par le précédent
gouvernement et jouent un rôle
très important.
Le gouvernement et la Première
ministre, et le président l'on
dit, ce métier de médiation doit
être reconnu et doit avoir de la
reconnaissance et de la
simplification, notamment dans le
recrutement des adultes-relais.
Nous y travaillons dans le cadre
de Quartiers 2030.
Nous sommes auprès des
associations qui sont l'alpha et
l'oméga de la réussite de la
politique de la Ville dans nos
quartiers populaires.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Sansu.
- Nicolas Sansu: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, un an
après la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale du groupe communiste
et l'excellent travail qu'elle a
fourni, la Cour des comptes vient
de vous rappeler à l'ordre sur le
recours excessif
et coûteux aux cabinets de conseil
privés.
Depuis 2017, le coût des dépenses
de conseil, hors informatique, a
atteint 230 millions d'euros.
Cette dérive, sur fond de
copinage, se matérialise par de
nombreux scandales.
Le recours à McKinsey pendant la
crise sanitaire, le recours aux
conseils privés fréquents.
Il faut renforcer la transparence,
encadrer le recours aux
prestations de conseil, prévenir
les conflits d'intérêts et les
annihiler si possible.
La majorité refuse d'inscrire cela
à l'ordre du jour malgré les
demandes répétées de mon groupe.
Quant à votre gouvernement, il
s'est contenté d'une modeste
circulaire de janvier 2022.
Il est temps d'agir concrètement
pour mettre fin à cette gabegie.
Ce recours excessif aux
prestations de conseil privé
constitue une déviance d'autant
plus grande qu'il s'agit souvent
de démanteler les services et la
fonction publique.
C'est votre choix politique.
Nous rendrons demain un rapport
sur le champ de compétence de la
proposition de loi.
Si le recours aux prestations de
conseil dans les collectivités
locales doit aussi être étudié, il
ne peut être un prétexte pour
repousser sans cesse l'examen du
texte sénatorial.
Ne tentez pas d'enterrer ce sujet.
La confiance de nos concitoyens
dans notre démocratie se construit
aussi à l'aune de tels actes.
N'abîmez pas une fois de plus le
Parlement et par là-même la
République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Stanislas
Guerini, ministre de la
Transformation et de la Fonction
publique.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci.
Monsieur le député Nicolas Sansu,
vous avez mentionné dans votre
question le rapport récent de la
Cour des comptes et les travaux
menés avec Marie Lebec, suite à la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale.
Il est sain et utile que de tels
travaux puissent se conduire.
Cela permet d'établir la réalité
des faits.
Quelle est-elle?
Toutes les recommandations de la
Cour des comptes, elles ont été
mises en oeuvre par le
gouvernement.
Soyons factuels.
Janvier 2022, circulaire du
Premier ministre pour établir une
doctrine et fixer un cap, la
réduction de 15% des dépenses de
recours aux prestations externes.
Fin 2022, nouvel accord
interministériel qui encadre
l'intégralité des recours aux
dépenses de conseil.
Il a été publié officiellement.
Il intègre la quasi-totalité des
recommandations sénatoriales.
Encadrement des montants,
interdiction des droits de suite,
destruction des données chez les
cabinets de conseil et intégration
chez les administrations,
interdiction de démarchage...
Lorsqu'on évoque les faits, cela
vous intéresse un peu moins.
Enfin, en 2022, publication d'une
annexe qui est maintenant inscrite
au PLF à disposition de tous les
parlementaires et de tous les
Français.
Elle recense point par point
toutes les prestations de conseil
des cabinets ministériels.
Les résultats sont là.
Cela vous intéressera, puisque
vous faites partie de ceux qui
veulent nous aider.
Là où nous nous étions fixés une
réduction de 15% des dépenses,
pour l'année 2022, on est à 35%.
C'est le fruit de l'action de ce
gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Thierry.
- Nicolas Thierry: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé.
Vous avez probablement pris
connaissance du pré-rapport
relatif au glyphosate publié le 6
juillet.
En 2017, Emmanuel Macon s'était
engagé pour une interdiction du
glyphosate.
Il disait: "Le glyphosate, il n'y
a aucun rapport qui dit que c'est
innocent.
Demain, les ouvriers agricoles,
les consommateurs me diront que je
savais et me regarderont les yeux
dans les yeux."
Quand Emmanuel Macon disait cela,
il portait la voix des
scientifiques français.
L'INSERM confirme une nouvelle
fois en 2021 que deux études
mettent en évidence les dommages
toxiques, les cassures de l'ADN.
Les preuves de la toxicité du
glyphosate sont fortes.
Autre conclusion émanant d'autres
instituts français: l'impact du
glyphosate sur la fertilité
animale et humaine est fort.
Pourtant, on continue à dire que
"le glyphosate ne présente pas de
problème critique".
En s'appuyant sur les études
fournies par les instituts
agrochimiques, les instituts de
recherche financés par ces
instituts, les résultats sont
différents, sans surprise.
Ma question est donc simple: quand
allez-vous sortir du glyphosate?
Les instituts de recherche sont
unanimes.
Quand l'engagement sera-t-il
effectif?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Marc
Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Vous avez raison, il faut se baser
sur la science.
Je ne trie pas la science.
Ce n'est pas parce que le
thermomètre ne vous plaît pas
qu'il faut casser le thermomètre.
Si l'on rentre dans cette logique,
il y a quelques semaines, vous me
vilipendez parce que je posais une
question de chronologie sur ces
données.
Ne rentrez pas dans cette logique
qui consiste à remettre en cause
les agences, y compris les agences
européennes.
N'opposez pas les agences
européennes et les agences
françaises.
L'Agence européenne des produits
chimiques a conclu à l'absence de
lien cancérogène, mutagène ou
toxique à la reproduction.
Néanmoins, quelle est la position
que va porter la France?
C'est la position que, partout où
peut trouver des alternatives pour
sortir du glyphosate, on puisse
avancer sur le sujet.
Nous avons des résultats.
Depuis 2017, c'est -27% sur les
usages.
C'est -30% sur l'achat du
glyphosate.
Il n'y a pas besoin d'attendre
l'Europe pour avancer.
Il faut trouver de la cohérence.
La cohérence, c'est de chercher
des alternatives, c'est de pouvoir
se dire quand il y a des impacts:
la cohérence, ça ne peut pas être
défendre
des "y a qu'à/faut qu'on'.
Cette trajectoire est exigeante
mais nécessaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Nicolas Thierry: Je prends bonne
note que, sur une question de
santé publique majeure, ce soit le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui
réponde.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Aurélien
Lopez-Liguori.
- Aurélien Lopez-Liguori: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au garde des
Sceaux.
Monsieur le ministre, notre statut
de député de la nation ne nous
place pas au-dessus des lois.
Au contraire, ils nous obligent
envers la France et les Français.
Pourtant, des élus de la NUPES
présents dans cet hémicycle nous
ont offert une fois encore un
spectacle consternant ce samedi en
participant à une manifestation
interdite.
Ils se sont pavanés sous les cris
de "tout le monde déteste la
police".
L'extrême-gauche nous prouve sa
haine des forces de l'ordre et, à
travers elle, sa haine de la
France.
J'accuse mesdames Panot, Rousseau,
Simonnet et Keke, monsieur Boyard,
Portes, Coquerel, j'accuse La
France Insoumise et les
écologistes de souffler sur les
braises de l'anarchie.
Vous avez choisi votre camp en
affichant votre soutien au gang
Traoré, une famille qui a, à son
actif, des dizaines de
condamnations pour violences
aggravées, cambriolage, trafic de
stupéfiants et même violences.
Votre manie pathologique de vous
entourer de délinquants dangereux
et de fanatiques sans limites ou
de milices violentes en dit long
sur le projet que vous portez pour
notre pays.
Ce n'est pas à l'Assemblée de
sanctionner ses députés mais aux
Français, dans les urnes, et c'est
à la justice d'agir.
Une manifestation interdite est
interdite pour tout le monde, pour
les députés.
Ce n'est pas moi qui le dis mais
c'est le code pénal, que certains
seraient avisés de relire.
Monsieur le garde des Sceaux, le
message que vous avez adressé au
procureur après les manifestations
scandaleuses de Sainte-Soline doit
être appliqué à tout le monde.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti, garde des Sceaux
et ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: A quelques
jours de ces émeutes, monsieur le
député Lopez-Liguori, je trouve
qu'il est effectivement scandaleux
de voir des élus de la République,
avec leur écharpe tricolore, ne
pas quitter les lieux lorsqu'on
crie "tout le monde déteste la
police".
Moi, j'aime la police, j'aime la
République, j'aime la Constitution
de 1958.
Monsieur le député, le garde des
Sceaux n'a pas la possibilité de
donner des directives de poursuite
au parquet.
Vous avez toujours la possibilité
d'adresser au procureur de la
République un article 40 car,
effectivement, participer à une
manifestation interdite est une
infraction.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Philippe Ardouin.
Madame la présidente Panot, vous
n'avez pas la parole.
- Jean-Philippe Ardouin: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à Jean-Noël
Barrot, ministre délégué chargé de
Transition numérique et des
Télécommunications.
La liberté à laquelle nous sommes
tous viscéralement attachés a une
part d'ombre qui tient dans le
sentiment d'impunité de certains
internautes.
Début 2019, et encore récemment,
le président de la République
s'est dit favorable à l'étude de
la levée de l'anonymat sur
Internet.
Je partage cette position
courageuse qu'il nous revient de
concrétiser.
Nous ne pouvons nous résoudre à
entendre ces récits d'hommes et de
femmes et bien trop souvent de
collégiens ou de lycéens victime
de moqueries, d'humiliations
gratuites sous couvert d'anonymat.
Certains de nos enfants vont
jusqu'à mettre fin à leurs jours
car, là où la chaleur des foyers
protégeait les collégiens, les
réseaux sociaux prolongent leur
chemin de croix jusqu'au domicile
familial.
C'est insupportable.
Nous devons trouver le juste
équilibre entre liberté et vie
privée des internautes et la
sanction des personnes qui en
abusent.
Nous devons être plus exigeants
avec les opérateurs numériques,
peu enclins à apporter leur
concours à la justice et à la
police.
Nous ne pouvons pas accepter que
des opérateurs protègent ceux qui
détruisent la vie de nos
concitoyens.
En février 2022, nous avons voté
une loi pour lutter contre le
harcèlement scolaire.
C'est une étape essentielle qu'il
nous faut prolonger.
Peut-on envisager la mise en place
de mesures d'identification plus
contraignantes sur les réseaux
sociaux afin de retrouver plus
facilement les auteurs de
harcèlement en ligne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Noël
Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot: Merci.
Vous avez raison, le
cyberharcèlement est un fléau dont
tous les Français peuvent être
victimes, à tous les âges de la vie
et plus particulièrement les
femmes, plus souvent victimes de
cyberharcèlement, et évidemment
les enfants, puisque dès
le collège, le harcèlement se
déplace de la cour d'école jusque
les réseaux sociaux et les
Smartphones.
Permettez-moi de rappeler qu'il
n'y a pas d'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux, que nul ne peut
impunément propager la haine sur
Internet, même derrière un pseudo
ou un avatar.
Les agresseurs de Mila, les
agresseurs du chanteur Eddy de
Pretto, ont été identifiés,
traduits devant la justice et
condamnés à des peines de prison
allant jusqu'à un an
d'emprisonnement et 5000 euros
d'amende.
Il nous faut accroître la
responsabilité de chacun.
Ce sera le cas avec l'entrée en
vigueur du règlement sur les
services numériques, qui
contraindra les opérateurs à
prendre des mesures de protection
de l'enfance sous peine de
sanctions allant jusqu'à 6% du
chiffre d'affaires mondial.
Ce sera le cas avec l'entrée en
vigueur de plusieurs lois qui vont
activer la responsabilité
parentale.
Ce sera le cas avec la mise en
oeuvre du projet de loi numérique
adopté la semaine dernière au
Sénat, qui va permettre aux juges
de prononcer une peine
complémentaire de bannissement des
réseaux sociaux pendant une
période de six mois lorsqu'une
personne est reconnue coupable de
faits de cyberharcèlement
scolaire.
La lutte contre le
cyberharcèlement scolaire comme la
lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire suppose une approche de
bout en bout.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
madame la Première ministre a
convoqué vendredi une réunion pour
préparer dès la rentrée un plan
d'action globale pour lutter
contre le harcèlement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est monsieur Philippe
Juvin.
- Philippe Juvin: Cette question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Santé.
Nous manquons de médecins partout.
Pourquoi?
Nous n'en formons pas assez.
Nous l'avons dit 1000 fois.
Vous devez doubler le numerus
clausus.
En attendant cette décision, nous
vous faisons une proposition pour
augmenter dès maintenant le nombre
de médecins en France.
Comme chaque année, un concours va
être organisé pour permettre à des
médecins diplômés à l'étranger
d'exercer en France.
Cette année, il y a 20.000
candidats.
C'est formidable.
Pourtant, décidément, c'est une
manie de votre administration,
vous avez fixé un numerus clausus.
Vous avez décidé que sur ces
20.000, nous en prendrions 2700,
pas plus.
Les Français n'ont plus de
médecins!
Pourquoi n'en prendre que 2700?
Ca n'a aucun sens.
Prenez tous ceux qui ont le
niveau.
C'est un examen, pas un concours.
Seconde proposition: les 2700 sont
affectés dans des hôpitaux pour
deux ans.
C'est très bien.
Faites pareil dans nos
territoires, dans nos communes,
nos maisons de santé.
Si la moitié avait le niveau, et
l'examen le dira, ça ferait 30 ou
40 médecins généralistes dans
chacun de nos départements.
C'est énorme.
Monsieur le ministre, il y a des
solutions aux déserts médicaux,
mais il y a une condition: il faut
changer de méthode.
Il faut arrêter avec toutes ces
décisions de numerus clausus
prises à Paris qui sont inadaptées
aux besoins de nos territoires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun,
ministre de la Santé, et de la
Prévention.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député Philippe Juvin, merci de
mettre un peu le doigt sur ces
problématiques de praticiens avec
des diplômes hors de l'Union
Européenne.
Concernant ces praticiens, ils
bénéficient d'un parcours exigeant
pour la reconnaissance de leur
diplôme.
Ils passent un examen.
Ensuite, ils passent devant des
jurys en fonction de leur
spécialité.
Les jurys peuvent leur demander de
faire des stages complémentaires
dans le cadre d'une formation pour
être au niveau.
Concernant l'ensemble de ces
problématiques, nous avons conduit
une sécurisation des 3800 médecins
qui étaient en attente de
validation pendant cette période
Covid.
Ils ont été validés.
Ils sont maintenant sécurisés dans
nos établissements.
Le concours permet tous les ans
d'apporter 2700 médecins
supplémentaires dans l'ensemble
des spécialités.
Nous ne faisons rien?
Si.
Dans cette assemblée, vous avez
validé la PPL de votre collègue
qui va nous permettre d'accélérer
ces validations, de faciliter ces
certifications et de former encore
plus de médecins.
Nous avons également validé dans
cet hémicycle la possibilité
d'ajouter à ces médecins la notion
de passeport talent.
Nous allons chercher des
professionnels talentueux pour les
faire venir encore plus rapidement
dans nos établissements.
Il est surprenant de voir que les
députés du Rassemblement National,
pourtant très prompts à nous dire
que nous ne faisons rien, ont
voulu supprimer ces articles.
Ils verront quelles en seront les
conséquences sur leurs
territoires.
Vous avez fait un lapsus en
parlant de numerus clausus pour la
formation de médecine.
Il s'agit d'un autre dispositif
qui a vu l'augmentation de 15% des
étudiants.
On peut considérer que ce n'est
pas assez, mais si on veut garder
la qualité pour former des
médecins, il faut aussi des
enseignants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Philippe Juvin: Je n'ai pas bien
saisi votre réponse.
Si vous ne doublez pas le numerus
clausus, il faut changer votre
administration.
Vous êtes là pour imposer votre
politique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, mon cher collègue.
La parole est au groupe LIOT.
- Guy Bricout: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin.
En mars 2017, le plan préfecture
nouvelle génération a été présenté
aux Français.
Il visait à simplifier, à
accélérer et à améliorer la
délivrance des titres en
transférant aux mairies
volontaires le renouvellement des
passeports et des cartes
d'identité.
Or, nous sommes passés de 12 jours
pour obtenir un rendez-vous en
avril 2021 à plus de 65 jours en
moyenne depuis l'année 2022.
Selon un rapport d'information sur
la délivrance des titres
d'identité, ces faits sont avérés.
Celui-ci démontre que le délai de
la demande s'est accrue.
Il est passé à 20 jours au lieu de
15.
Le délai ne cesse d'augmenter
depuis 2018.
Les passeports et les cartes
d'identité ne sont pas les seuls
titres touchés.
Alors que la France est l'un des
pays les plus visités au monde, si
ce n'est le premier, le délai
d'obtention des visas pose un réel
problème pour les étrangers
souhaitant s'installer en France.
Nous avons échangé avec les
députés sénégalais.
Ces derniers nous ont fait part de
délais qu'ils jugent anormaux.
Alors que le Sénégal est un ami de
la France, il leur faut environ
six mois pour obtenir un visa.
Cela nuit à l'image de notre pays
à l'international.
De plus, par expérience
personnelle, le contrôle effectué
par la police aux frontières dans
les aéroports français est lui
aussi fastidieux.
En Chine, il m'a fallu moins d'un
quart d'heure pour passer tous les
contrôles d'identité.
En France, il m'a fallu quasiment
2h lors de mon retour.
Afin de répondre aux attentes des
Français et des touristes, qu'en
est-il des solutions annoncées par
le gouvernement en avril 2023?
Que pense le gouvernement sur les
propositions du rapport dont j'ai
parlé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, vous avez posé deux
questions.
La première est sur la délivrance
des titres d'identité par les
préfectures et les
sous-préfectures ainsi que les
mairies.
Vous connaissez les raisons pour
lesquelles il y a eu du retard: la
période Covid, notamment.
Nous avons décidé d'un plan massif
pour délivrer ces pièces
d'identité.
Ca a permis aujourd'hui de réduire
dans votre département à moins de
30 jours le délai pour obtenir sa
pièce d'identité.
Il y a des places et des créneaux
disponibles pour renouveler sa
carte d'identité.
Il n'y a plus de problèmes pour
les vacances de cet été.
Pour les visas, que nous nous
partageons avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur et le ministère des
Affaires étrangères, il y a du
retard pour plusieurs raisons.
Le président de la République a
commandé un rapport.
Ce rapport nous a été rendu.
Nous allons en tirer toutes les
conséquences pour améliorer le
processus qui permet aux étrangers
de venir sur le sol national en
obtenant un visa.
Vous avez cité plusieurs pays amis
de la France.
Vous savez que nous avons à faire
face à de l'immigration
irrégulière, qui prend souvent
l'excuse du visa de travail pour
rester sur le territoire national.
Nous devons améliorer nos
processus pour permettre
d'accueillir des étudiants, des
touristes ou encore des
scientifiques, qui veulent venir
en France.
Nous devons en même temps lutter
contre cette immigration
irrégulière.
Des moyens supplémentaires seront
mis.
Il y a des grandes transformations
numériques qui sont en train
d'être mises en place.
Evidemment, il faut un lien plus
fort avec le pays.
Je me suis rendu moi-même au
Sénégal pour avoir une politique
de visas plus connue des deux
côtés.
La comparaison avec la Chine est
un peu étonnante.
Là-bas, ils ont la reconnaissance
faciale, ce qui facilite les
contrôles de police.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
François Gernigon.
- François Gernigon: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Eric Dupond-Moretti, ministre de
la Justice.
L'autorité d'un professeur,
l'autorité d'un officier de
gendarmerie, l'autorité d'un juge,
l'autorité d'un éducateur et même
l'autorité d'un parent...
L'autorité de l'Etat, en fin de
compte.
Qu'en reste-t-il aujourd'hui?
Ces figures, autrefois respectées,
voient désormais leur autorité
constamment remise en question.
Ca n'est pas acceptable.
Nous ne pouvons nous résoudre à
accepter facilement ce déclin.
En tant qu'ancien maire, je l'ai
vu de mes yeux.
Des enfants livrés à eux-mêmes
adoptaient de mauvais
comportements sans que les
services sociaux ou judiciaires ne
soient en capacité de leur offrir
des solutions adaptées.
Les récentes émeutes dont nous
avons été les témoins en sont une
preuve supplémentaire.
Un certain nombre de jeunes se
sont livrés à ces actes de
délinquance et ont été dirigés
vers des centres éducatifs fermés.
Ces structures adaptées jouent un
rôle crucial.
Je tiens à saluer l'engagement de
l'ensemble des acteurs, et des
éducateurs notamment, qui tentent
chaque jour de changer des
trajectoires de vie.
Mais leurs capacités sont
limitées.
Malgré le programme de création de
nouveaux centres, annoncé en 2018,
il nous faut aller plus loin.
Ces centres doivent évoluer pour
accueillir davantage les jeunes
qui sont en décrochage dès la
première transgression, ceux que
les parents n'arrivent plus à
contrôler avant qu'ils ne se
perdent dans une spirale de
délinquance toujours plus grave.
Comment pouvons-nous faire évoluer
ces centres pour les ouvrir au
plus grand nombre de jeunes?
Il en va de l'avenir de notre pays
et surtout de l'avenir de chacun
des membres de notre République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Eric Dupond-Moretti,
garde des Sceaux et ministre de la
Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Monsieur le
député François Gernigon, je viens
de lire la tribune que vous avez
publiée dans Le Courrier de
l'Ouest.
Permettez-moi de vous dire que
j'en partage les termes.
Une partie de notre jeunesse, fort
heureusement pas toute notre
jeunesse, est à la dérive.
Cette partie de notre jeunesse a
besoin de figures tutélaires, en
réalité.
Parents, enseignants, magistrats,
policiers...
Ce qui vient de se dérouler nous
oblige.
Je voudrais vous apporter une
réponse claire à ce que nous avons
fait.
D'abord, sur la responsabilité des
parents, j'ai rappelé au procureur
de la République que c'était une
infraction que de mal s'occuper de
ses enfants quand on en avait la
capacité.
J'ai pris un flyer qui ne mérite
pas d'être moqué.
Sur beaucoup de flyers, on
explique toujours ce que sont les
droits et rarement ce que sont les
devoirs.
Moi, j'ai souhaité rappeler à la
fois qu'il y avait une
responsabilité pénale, qu'elle
était double, une responsabilité
civile.
S'agissant du judiciaire, j'ai
demandé une réponse rapide,
systématique, appropriée.
La justice, je le dis, a été au
rendez-vous de ses obligations
dans cette période si difficile.
C'est aussi grâce à la justice que
l'ordre républicain a été rétabli.
S'agissant de l'Education
nationale, ça n'est pas mon
périmètre, mais avec le ministre
de l'Education nationale, nous
avons mis en place un parcours qui
est un mélange de règles de droit
et de règles civiques.
Tout simplement, cela s'applique à
tous les élèves dès la troisième.
Un partenariat armée-justice est
disponible.
Les centres éducatifs fermés, nous
en avons 54.
Quatre nouveaux vont ouvrir
bientôt.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
José Beaurain pour le
Rassemblement National.
- José Beaurain: Mes chers
collègues, ma question s'adresse à
monsieur Roland Lescure, ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie en
France.
Le 11 juin dernier, au sein d'une
commune, s'est déroulée une
consultation citoyenne à
l'initiative du maire quant au
projet de construction d'une usine
d'un industriel danois spécialiste
dans la production de laine de
roche.
Cette laine de roche est un
isolant important dans la
rénovation thermique des
bâtiments.
Cependant, alors que l'industrie
danoise s'est défendue à raison,
les effets de cette laine
continuent à inquiéter les
habitants.
Ce suffrage qui avait pour
question : "Etes-vous pour ou
contre l'implantation de cette
usine sur votre territoire ?"
a vu le non l'emporter.
Le préfet a décrété et a décidé
que cette consultation citoyenne
était illégale et a décidé de ne
pas écouter la volonté populaire.
Ce n'est pas une première pour le
préfet.
Il avait déjà refusé d'entendre la
voix des habitants sur une
consultation précédente, à
l'initiative de 18 communes qui
s'opposaient à l'implantation d'un
parc éolien dans le sud du
département.
Bien que nous ayons affaire un
projet industriel très intéressant
sur le plan économique et social,
son implantation géographique pose
question.
Une solution claire, plus précise
et plus adaptée aurait pu être
trouvée si une consultation
préalable avait été menée auprès
des habitants.
Afin de trouver un emplacement
plus judicieux...
En conséquence, pour éviter les
problèmes démocratiques locaux de
plus en plus fréquents, je vous le
demande, comment allez-vous
revaloriser pour chaque projet
d'implantation industrielle
susceptible d'avoir un impact sur
l'environnement des consultations
citoyennes préalables, qui
auraient une envergure
décisionnelle définitive et
sanctuarisée?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roland Lescure,
ministre chargé de l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure: Merci pour votre
question, monsieur le député.
Vous et votre groupe aviez
l'occasion de voter un très beau
projet industriel.
Je regrette que votre groupe ne
l'ait pas voté.
J'en profite pour remercier toutes
celles et ceux qui ont soutenu ce
projet de loi qui vise à libérer
du foncier, du financement, et à
simplifier les procédures.
Je vais y venir, monsieur le
député.
Elles font en sorte que ces
projets industriels créent de la
prospérité et de l'acceptabilité
sociale.
Dans ce projet de loi, nous
augmentons la durée de l'enquête
publique.
Nous obligeons des rencontres
publiques officielles de manière à
améliorer l'acceptabilité de ces
dossiers qui sont souvent des
dossiers importants pour l'emploi
et pour les territoires, mais qui
sont parfois l'objet de débats
tendus.
C'est le cas du projet auquel vous
faites référence.
La plupart des élus étaient
derrière ce projet.
Ce projet a fait l'objet d'une
enquête approfondie et d'une
consultation, qui, elle, n'était
pas légale.
On se retrouve aujourd'hui face à
des recours qui vont être traités
dans le projet de loi industriel.
J'engage les membres de votre
groupe à le voter.
Cela va permettre de simplifier
tout ça.
C'est un défi énorme qui nous
attend.
Les industriels et les porteurs de
projets doivent être associés de
manière à s'assurer que tout le
monde soit derrière ce projet.
Des procédures judiciaires sont en
cours.
Attendons de voir quel sort sera
donné à ces procédures.
J'engage tous les porteurs de
projets
à s'assurer que l'ensemble des
parties prenantes soient
consultées dans le cadre de ces
projets.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
Il n'y a plus du tout de temps,
mon cher collègue.
Désolée.
La parole est à monsieur
Laurent Esquenet-Goxes pour le
groupe démocrate.
- Laurent Esquenet-Goxes: Ma
question s'adresse au ministre
chargé de la Transition numérique.
Le poids des mots, le choc des
photos, ce slogan longtemps scandé
par un célèbre journal français
pourrait être celui des réseaux
sociaux.
Ce sont les photos de pillage en
masse qui ont choqué nos
concitoyens.
Il en va de même pour les vidéos
qui appellent aux violences.
Cela a conduit aux destructions
que nous déplorons.
Pour amplifier l'action des
plates-formes, nous devons
renforcer la responsabilité de
modération.
Toutefois, ces responsabilités ne
doivent pas conduire à enfreindre
la liberté d'expression.
L'héritage de la Révolution, la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
édicte en son article 11 que la
libre circulation des pensées et
des opinions est un des droits les
plus précieux de l'homme.
Mirabeau ou La Fayette n'avaient
pas en tête que la liberté
s'exercerait en ligne.
Nous devons pourtant mesurer
l'ampleur de notre vie numérique.
Les jeunes s'informent sur TikTok.
Les moins jeunes trouvent un
emploi sur LinkedIn.
Tous renforcent leurs liens sur
Facebook, Snapchat et Twitter.
Alors que certains appellent à
casser du maire, des commerces,
quelles sanctions peut-on leur
appliquer?
Comment peut-on s'assurer que
chaque réponse soit proportionnée
et individualisée de façon à
garantir la liberté d'expression?
Comment faire en sorte que ces
plates-formes ne se contentent pas
seulement de satisfaire leurs
intérêts privés, mais prennent
bien en compte l'intérêt général?
La réponse est sans doute
européenne.
C'est à cette échelle que l'action
sera plus forte et que pourra
cesser enfin l'effet
multiplicateur des réseaux.
Que peut faire le gouvernement
pour assurer un espace numérique,
libre et apaisé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
Jean-Noël Barrot, ministre délégué
chargé des Transitions numériques
et de la Communication.
- Jean-Noël Barrot: La liberté
d'expression, c'est le socle de
notre démocratie.
C'est un trésor qu'il nous faut
préserver et qu'il nous faut
chérir.
Les réseaux sociaux contribuent à
la liberté d'expression et à la
liberté d'information.
Dans bien des pays, pour les
peuples opprimés, les réseaux
sociaux sont le moyen de résister,
de s'informer, de communiquer.
Nos concitoyens utilisent
quotidiennement les réseaux
sociaux pour s'informer.
C'est d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'ils ont découvert
ébahis que des élus de la
République avaient choisi ce
week-end d'arborer l'écharpe
tricolore et de se joindre à une
manifestation, accompagnés de
chants contre la police.
La liberté d'expression ne vaut
pas liberté d'agression.
Nul ne peut agresser autrui sur
Internet.
Vous avez rappelé la situation
tragique que le pays a vécue...
Dans de nombreux départements, le
Val-de-Marne, les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques, la
Haute-Savoie, des individus ont
été retrouvés et traduits devant
la justice et condamnés à des
peines de prison pour des appels
au meurtre de policiers et de
gendarmes, d'agressions contre des
maires.
Ils ont également appelé à
détruire des commissariats et des
gendarmeries.
Nous avons besoin de toutes les
initiatives au niveau européen,
avec le règlement sur les services
numériques, que la France a porté.
Nous avons besoin des initiatives
parlementaires.
Nous avons besoin de l'initiative
gouvernementale, avec le projet de
loi que nous portons avec Bruno Le
Maire pour réguler l'espace
numérique.
Nous devons faire en sorte de
faire reculer l'insécurité que
rencontrent nos concitoyens sur
Internet.
Nous devons restaurer leur
confiance et réussir la transition
numérique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
Davy Rimane.
- Davy Rimane: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé, monsieur François
Braun.
On entend beaucoup parler de la
désertification médicale
dramatique qui progresse dans
l'Hexagone.
On entend aussi souvent parler de
l'état de santé et des populations
souvent précaires qui n'ont pas
beaucoup accès aux soins.
On oublie de préciser que les plus
grands déserts médicaux se
trouvent à des milliers de
kilomètres d'ici, en Guyane et à
Mayotte.
Je vous en parlais déjà il y a un
an de ça, dans un courrier.
Je suis ravi d'avoir l'occasion de
vous en parler de vive voix.
La Guyane, plus précisément le
centre hospitalier de Kourou, fait
face à une crise sociale en raison
d'un projet mal ficelé qui met
face-à-face des professionnels de
santé et une population en besoin
de soins vitaux.
Tout projet médical doit s'insérer
dans une structure hospitalière
déjà existante.
Le projet est une occasion inédite
pour votre ministère de repenser
l'offre de soins sur le territoire
guyanais.
On se retrouve, au lieu de ça,
face à un hôpital en grève parce
que des choix administratifs et
économiques inopportuns ont été
actés sans prendre en compte ceux
qui font tourner nos structures de
soins.
Un an après ma première demande de
rencontre, il est temps de
constater que les premières
victimes de cette situation sont
bien les citoyens et les
citoyennes et le personnel
soignant de ce territoire.
L'urgence est de mise.
A quand ce rendez-vous crucial
avec les parlementaires de Guyane?
En attendant votre venue en
Guyane, prenez conscience de la
situation.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun,
ministre de la Santé et de la
Prévention.
- François Braun: Merci de mettre
un éclairage sur la situation de
nos outre-mer et en particulier de
la Guyane et de Mayotte, qui sont
des territoires où les difficultés
de notre système de santé sont à
cultiver.
La politique de prévention doit
être développée encore plus devant
la paupérisation de certains
territoires.
On voit bien que certaines
décisions qui peuvent être prises
dans l'Hexagone s'adaptent
difficilement à ce qui se passe
dans nos territoires d'outre-mer.
Je pense en particulier à tous nos
travaux sur la territorialisation
qui peuvent se comprendre dans le
centre de la France et de
l'Hexagone et qui ne peuvent pas
apporter les mêmes réponses
lorsqu'on s'intéresse à des
territoires qui sont isolés.
La Guyane bénéficie des mesures
d'ordre général.
Il faut souligner que le nombre de
médecins au cours de ces 10
dernières années a augmenté de 73%
en Guyane alors que la population
a augmenté de 15%.
Concernant la ville, il y a une
structuration de l'offre de soins
que nous accompagnons
avec le déploiement depuis un an
pour améliorer les conditions de
travail.
Vous avez souligné la situation de
l'hôpital.
Je vous rejoins sur la situation
de l'hôpital universitaire de
Cayenne.
Le projet médical tient compte de
et bien entendu de l'hôpital de
Kourou, qui a des difficultés
financières majeurs en cours
d'expertise.
Je réponds bien volontiers à votre
habitation.
Je me rendrai en Guyane
prochainement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: monsieur
Davy Rimane?
- Davy Rimane: Le rendez-vous est
pris.
Je vous dis à demain.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur
Jean-Pierre Vigier pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Jean-Pierre Vigier: Dépendance,
perte de compétences, conflits
d'intérêts, voilà le résultat de
l'explosion des dépenses de
recours aux cabinets de conseil.
De 11 millions d'euros en 2014,
elles s'établissent à 200 millions
d'euros en 2022.
Il serait grand temps que votre
majorité reprenne la proposition
de loi votée au Sénat, encadrant
le recours de ces sociétés de
conseil.
En effet, la Cour des comptes a, à
son tour, posé la question de la
souveraineté de l'Etat face à des
consultants privés.
Ces conclusions sont accablantes.
Elles font état de véritables
intrusions de ces prestataires au
coeur des missions de l'Etat,
souvent au mépris des règles de la
commande publique et de toute
rigueur financière.
A l'heure où il est urgent de
financer des projets structurants
et d'investir en faveur des
services publics dans les
territoires ruraux, notamment en
Haute-Loire, ces dépenses
exorbitantes ne sont ni légitimes,
ni acceptables.
La prise de décision publique ne
se sous-traite pas.
Nous devons réapprendre à compter
sur une administration dévouée et
sur les 2,5 millions de
fonctionnaires attachés à leur
métier.
Aussi ma question est simple:
comment allez-vous abandonner la
conduite de nos politiques
publiques à des prestataires
privés dépourvus de légitimité
démocratique?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Stanislas Guerini,
ministre de la Transformation et
de la Fonction publiques.
- Stanislas Guerini: Monsieur le
député Jean-Pierre Vigier, vous
nous interrogez sur les résultats.
Vous me demandez ce qu'on attend
pour agir.
Nous n'avons pas attendu pour
agir.
Nous n'avons pas attendu le
rapport de la Cour des comptes
pour agir.
Nous n'avons pas attendu la
commission d'enquête pour agir.
proposition de loi pour agir.
Depuis deux ans, nous avons posé
des actes extrêmement concrets.
J'ai pu l'indiquer tout à l'heure.
Un nouvel accord pour encadrer le
recours aux prestations de
conseil.
Déontologie, transparence,
plafonnement des dépenses,
transparence budgétaire,
circulaires et résultats...
Les résultats sont là.
2021: 273 millions d'euros de
dépenses de conseil en stratégie.
2022: 173 millions d'euros.
Les résultats sont là.
Je suis
la courbe tous les mois.
La perspective de 2023, c'est une
trajectoire qui continuera à être
une trajectoire à la baisse.
J'essaie de vous apporter les
éléments les plus factuels
possibles.
Vous nous interrogez sur la
possibilité de poursuivre le débat
parlementaire.
Je ne me suis jamais soustrait au
débat parlementaire.
Jamais.
Le Sénat a posé dans une niche
parlementaire la proposition de
loi.
Chaque groupe dans cet hémicycle
peut en faire de même.
Je continuerai.
J'ai été à toute les auditions
parlementaires.
Il y en avait récemment.
Nous sommes prêts au débat, mais
sur la base de résultats factuels.
Et je vous le dis, les résultats
sont là.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Jean-Pierre Vigier: 200 millions
d'euros de dépenses de trop.
Redistribuez ces crédits aux
collectivités locales, elles en
ont grandement besoin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Manon
Meunier pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Manon Meunier: Madame la
Première ministre, la vie sur
Terre est-elle la dernière de vos
préoccupations?
Vous avez été condamnée pour
inaction sur le vivant.
Le tribunal administratif de Paris
a reconnu la responsabilité de
l'Etat dans l'effondrement de la
biodiversité.
Vous n'avez toujours pas répondu
au collectif Justice pour le
vivant qui a porté cette
condamnation.
Seriez-vous trop occupée à prendre
soin des profits records de LVMH?
Ce serait trop dommage, car pour
votre propre survie, vous êtes
plus dépendante du ver de terre
que de Bernard Arnault.
La biodiversité nous permet de
respirer et limite les pandémies
mondiales.
Ignorez votre condamnation, c'est
nous condamner tous.
Vous avez été reconnue coupable de
la pollution des eaux souterraines
par les pesticides et de la mort
de nos sols, coupable de soutenir
les lobbys de l'agrobusiness pour
qui l'agriculture ne rime qu'avec
superprofits.
Peu importe le vivant, pour eux,
le futur n'est que génétique
numérique robotique, glyphosates
et néonicotinoïdes.
Ce n'est pas durable.
Les scientifiques alertent.
L'Etat doit investir dans la
transition maintenant si nous ne
voulons pas que tout retombe sur
nos paysans.
Nous avons besoin de plus
d'agriculteurs sur nos terres,
pour une agriculture qui peut
composer avec les paysages et tout
simplement pour le droit des
générations futures à profiter
d'une nature préservée.
Mais votre préoccupation reste le
profit des puissants.
L'histoire vous jugera et vous ne
pourrez pas dire que vous ne
saviez pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés.
Madame la députée Manon Meunier,
je ne doute pas que vous ayez lu
attentivement les conclusions du
tribunal administratif du 29 juin.
Vous avez noté que le tribunal,
effectivement, nous condamne en
constatant que, malgré les
engagements pris par la France
entre 2009 et 2017, les quantités
de pesticides utilisés ont
augmenté de 20% en prenant les
nombres de doses unités.
20% entre 2009 et 2017.
Je cite le tribunal administratif
de Paris, "sans que la baisse
constatée plus récemment sur la
période 2018-2020 ne soit
suffisante pour inverser la
tendance".
Le tribunal administratif dit
qu'après 10 ans de hausse
continue, en particulier quand les
écologistes étaient au
gouvernement de ce pays, en
particulier quand la gauche était
aux responsabilités, depuis 2018,
les chiffres baissent en quantité.
Je vous renvoie au tribunal
administratif.
10% de baisse en moyenne sur les
trois dernières années.
93% de diminution des CMR1 sur la
période constatée.
Au lieu de polémiquer, il faut
rappeler la nécessité que nous
avons collectivement de relancer
un effort.
C'est voulu par la Première
ministre.
J'ai rappelé ce matin que ce
jugement nous obligeait et que
nous devions accélérer la
recherche, en particulier sur les
alternatives non-chimiques car les
pesticides sont mauvais pour la
biodiversité, pour nos sols et
aussi pour les agriculteurs qui
les épandent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Meunier?
- Manon Meunier: Vous condamnez
toujours le gouvernement Hollande,
mais laissez-moi vous rappeler que
le ministre de l'Economie, à
l'époque, était Emmanuel Macron.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Christophe Béchu: Madame
Meunier, je comprends que les
conclusions définitives du
tribunal vous contrarient et vous
essayez de vous défausser de la
responsabilité qui est celle d'une
partie de votre camp.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Clara
Chassaniol.
- Clara Chassaniol: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à la
ministre de l'Egalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et de
l'Egalité des chances.
Nous avons avancé dans la lutte
contre les LGBTQ-phobies avec
l'ouverture de la PMA à toutes les
femmes, l'interdiction des
thérapies de conversion ou
l'ouverture du don du sang pour
les personnes homosexuelles.
L'an dernier, à l'occasion des 40
ans de la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité, 40 millions
d'euros ont été débloqués et un
ambassadeur à l'égalité des droits
a été nommé.
Cependant, les atteintes commises
en fonction de l'identité sexuelle
ou de l'identité de genre sont en
augmentation.
Ces violences existent dans tous
les territoires.
La haine peut s'exprimer dans le
milieu scolaire, l'espace public,
le cercle familial, sportif ou
encore sur les réseaux sociaux.
Récemment, des dégradations de
centres LGBTQ ont eu lieu à La
Réunion, à Tours, à Perpignan.
Des jeunes à Brest appelaient à la
violence contre un bar LGBT lors
des émeutes récentes.
Les personnes LGBTQ doivent
pouvoir vivre dignement sans la
crainte du mépris.
Le plan que vous avez présenté
hier a fait l'objet de larges
consultations, en partenariat avec
les associations.
Je vous remercie pour votre
engagement à leurs côtés.
Hier, vous avez pris le temps
d'échanger avec des bénévoles de
SOS Homophobie sur l'annonce du
plan.
Pouvez-vous nous détailler les
mesures concrètes qui vont
permettre de changer les
mentalités et de sanctionner les
auteurs d'injures et d'agressions
partout où elles ont lieu pour que
les personnes LGBTQ ne soient plus
les cibles de la haine?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Isabelle
Rome.
- Isabelle Rome: Merci.
Madame la députée Clara
Chassaniol, oui, la haine
anti-LGBTQ+ persiste, malgré de
considérables avancées initiées
par le président de la République
depuis 2017.
Trop peu de personnes déposent
plainte.
Il nous faut intensifier notre
action, mieux identifier, mieux
prévenir, mieux traiter cette
haine.
C'est le sens du plan
gouvernemental dévoilé hier que je
porte.
Lutter contre la haine, c'est
d'abord faire appliquer le droit.
C'est aussi mettre fin à toute
impunité.
Cela passe par le renforcement des
formations des forces de l'ordre.
100% d'entre elles seront formées
d'ici mai 2024.
Cela passe aussi par une
répression efficace des actes et
des propos homophobes.
Les propos homophobes dans les
stades ne sont pas des
manifestations de liesse
populaire.
Ce sont des actes d'incitation à
la haine, des actes d'incitation à
la violence.
Ce sont des délits qui seront
sanctionnés systématiquement par
une peine complémentaire
d'interdiction des stades.
Cela passe aussi par un
renforcement et un éveil des
consciences.
C'est pour cela que nous avons un
plan de formation massif à l'égard
des professionnels de santé, des
professeurs, des agents publics,
des personnels de santé et des
encadrants des colonies de
vacances.
Dans notre société, aucun jeune ne
doit être abandonné.
Aucun jeune ne doit se sentir
rejeté.
Nous ouvrirons 10 nouveaux centres
d'accueil pour les personnes
LGBTQ+ sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'ici la fin du
quinquennat.
Je vous invite à défendre la
création de ces centres.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sandrine
Rousseau pour le groupe
écologiste.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Merci.
Puisqu'il y a eu une question tout
à l'heure sur la ligne de CNews,
je me permets de saluer la
rédaction du JDD qui est en grève.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, vous avez fait lever
l'Assemblée sur les policiers
morts au service et je me suis
levée.
Maintenant, je voudrais que nous
nous levions pour les victimes des
actions policières, Malik Oussekine,
Bouna Sarr Traoré, Steve Maia
Caniço, Adama Traoré,
Aboubakar Fofana, Cédric Chouviat et
Nahel.
Vous avez préparé vos éléments de
langage sur notre participation à
une manifestation interdite.
Que les immenses Martin Luther
King, Gandhi ou Mandela nous
regardent.
Laissons ces personnages à
l'histoire.
La Constitution garantit le droit
de manifester en sécurité.
Vous en faites un usage politique.
Vous interdisez les manifestations
écologiques, les manifestations
antiracistes.
Les milices d'extrême droite ne
déposent pas de demande
d'autorisation avant leurs
manifestations alors vous les
laissez à l'écart de vos
critiques.
Qu'y a-t-il de commun entre la
répression violente des gilets
jaunes, l'arrestation de Youssef
Traoré, les exactions violentes au
moment de la mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites?
C'est la BRAV-M, une unité dont
est issu le policier qui a tiré
sur Nahel, une unité visée par
plusieurs enquêtes judiciaires.
Il y a beaucoup d'enquêtes contre
cette BRAV-M, dont certains
membres viennent de la CSI 93, la
même...
Le micro est coupé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin a: Madame la
députée, permettez-moi de vous
corriger.
Ce ne sont pas des policiers de la
BRAV-M qui ont tiré sur le jeune
conducteur de Nanterre, ce sont
des motards du 92.
Vous avez manifestement confondu
des choses dans votre déclaration.
Par ailleurs, madame la députée,
je crois que vous vous payez de
mots.
"Que Gandhi et Mandela vous
regardent", je crois que c'est
excessif.
En revanche, les Français vous
regardent et je regrette ce tweet
que vous avez depuis supprimé: "Le
tir, même en cas de terrorisme, ne
doit pas être l'option
privilégiée."
Madame la députée, c'est dommage
qu'il ne vous reste pas quelques
secondes, je vous aurais posé la
question: est-ce que vous pensez
que le terrorisme est un cas
extrême pour les policiers ou pas?
J'ai aussi lu ce tweet que vous
n'avez malheureusement pas retiré
sur le slogan "Tout le monde
déteste la police".
Je l'ai entendu dans des cortèges
divers.
C'est une alerte.
Quand des milices ou des
manifestations d'extrême droite
crient "tout le monde déteste les
étrangers", il faut condamner ces
propos qui sont un crime contre la
pensée.
Vous n'avez toujours pas retiré ce
tweet concernant le lien que vous
faites entre le pillage et la
pauvreté.
Quelle insulte envers les pauvres
et les plus modestes qui tous les
jours travaillent, ont le goût de
l'effort et de l'éducation.
Ce n'est pas Gandhi et ce n'est
pas Mandela qui vous regardent, ce
sont vos électeurs qui doivent se
dire qu'ils ce sont peut-être
trompés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Mickaël
Bouloux.
- Mickaël Bouloux: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, l'été
dernier a été le plus chaud jamais
enregistré en Europe.
2,3 degrés au-dessus des normales.
Cela a causé plus de 500.000 morts
entre le 30 mai et le 4 septembre
sur le continent européen.
Les chercheurs de l'Inserm ont par
ailleurs démontré que la France
était le pays qui avait enregistré
la plus forte augmentation des
températures par rapport aux
moyennes de saison: +2,43 degrés.
Notre pays arrive en quatrième
position quant au nombre de décès
avec 4807 morts liés à la chaleur.
Selon les dernières données
récentes, la trajectoire des
températures de 2023 s'emballe et
est particulièrement inquiétante.
Nous pouvons parler d'une
catastrophe sanitaire.
Les premières victimes sont les
populations les plus précaires qui
vivent dans des passoires
thermiques.
Il y a plus d'un mois, a été rendu
un rapport appelant à une
programmation pour un
investissement sur trois décennies
et préconisant de mettre en place
un impôt exceptionnel et
temporaire sur les patrimoines
financiers des Français les plus
aisés, à hauteur de 5 milliards
d'euros par an pour participer aux
30 milliards d'euros annuels
nécessaires de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires sur ces sujets.
La décarbonation est un sujet qui
touche à la survie de l'humanité.
On est face à un mur et il faut
trouver les moyens de financer ce
mur.
Chacun doit prendre sa part selon
ses revenus.
Qu'en est-il aujourd'hui, madame
la Première ministre, de la mise
en oeuvre d'une nécessaire
fiscalité écologique planifiée,
tournée résolument vers la justice
sociale?
Il s'agit d'accélérer les dépenses
climatiques nécessaires à toutes
et tous par de nouveaux moyens.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Christophe Béchu
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Mickaël
Bouloux.
D'abord, vous avez cité le rapport
de monsieur Pisani-Ferry, qui
chiffre la hauteur de la marche.
Le premier élément a été apporté
par la Première ministre ce
week-end, avec les augmentations
de crédits à hauteur de 7
milliards.
Ce budget permettra de montrer
qu'en matière de ferroviaire, il y
a des dépenses qu'il faut engager
maintenant, même si elles ne
trouvent pas de crédit dès l'année
2024.
C'est bien sur la base de ces 60
milliards d'euros supplémentaires
que nous devons trouver, que nous
construisons la feuille de route
sous l'autorité d'Elisabeth Borne
de la planification écologique.
Le financement repose sur une
pluralité d'acteurs, y compris sur
les entreprises privées, sur leur
capacité d'engager des dépenses de
transition et sur une évolution
des
parties des dépenses publiques.
Nous avons des surplus de crédit à
mettre en particulier sur la
rénovation énergétique et les
transports.
L'ambition du gouvernement est de
faire en sorte que ce soit en
fonction des émissions que nous
puissions augmenter les
contributions.
Je vous renvoie la décision que
nous avons prise il y a quelques
mois d'augmenter de 70% la
fiscalité du kérosène pour la
ligne sur l'essence, de manière à
faire en sorte que les avions et,
en particulier les plus petits
d'entre eux, soient taxés de la
même manière que les voitures.
Cela n'est qu'un premier pas dans
le cadre du verdissement des
dépenses.
Nous allons revenir sur un certain
nombre de dépenses brunes,
toujours autour de l'aviation, des
sociétés autoroutières et d'autres
de ce type je vous donne
rendez-vous dans quelques mois.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Mickaël Bouloux: Que feront tous
les plus aisés sur une planète
brûlée?
Il faut les faire contribuer.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Quentin
Bataillon.
- Quentin Bataillon: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie, des Finances et de
la Souveraineté industrielle et
numérique.
Le député de Saint-Etienne vous
interroge aujourd'hui.
Au niveau international comme à
l'international, nous connaissons
Saint-Etienne pour son club de
foot, pour son histoire minière et
industrielle avec sa manufacture
d'armée Manufrance, avec sa cité
du design, avec une solidarité
exceptionnel qui se traduit par
une vie associative forte et par
le groupe Casino.
Cette marque de grande
distribution, si connue et si
aimée des Français.
Casino a toujours placé les
consommateurs au coeur de sa
politique et de ses innovations.
Ce sont les salariés de Casino qui
ont inventé le libre-service, les
chaînes de froid et même les dates
limites de vente.
Casino est un groupe qui s'est
bâti autour
de Saint-Etienne et Saint-Etienne
s'est bâtie autour du groupe
Casino.
Ce sont 2000 employés qui
travaillent au siège social.
Salariés, syndicats, élus locaux
et habitants, nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire que Casino fait
partie du patrimoine stéphanois.
Malheureusement, le groupe Casino
est aujourd'hui en situation très
difficile.
Le 3 juillet dernier, deux offres
de reprise ont été concrétisées
et, à ce stade, aucune garantie
n'a été apportée pour le siège de
Saint-Etienne.
L'inquiétude des salariés mais
aussi des Stéphanois est
grandissante.
Pour ces raisons, je vous demande
vos intentions pour conserver le
siège social et les activités du
groupe Casino à Saint-Etienne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Madame la présidente, mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Quentin Bataillon.
Comme vous l'avez très bien dit,
le groupe Casino rencontre depuis
plusieurs mois des difficultés
opérationnelles et financières
majeures.
Il a accumulé 6,5 milliards
d'euros de dettes, mettant en
péril dans les semaines qui
viennent son activité et les
50.000 emplois qui sont en jeu et,
face à cette situation, nous avons
pris la décision d'autoriser le
groupe Casino à reporter le
paiement de ses charges sociales
et fiscales.
C'est une aide de 300 millions
d'euros que nous avons ainsi
apportée au groupe Casino, qui
devra évidemment être remboursée
par les repreneurs à l'Etat.
Des propositions de reprise ont pu
être faites.
Deux propositions ont été faites.
Elles sont solides.
L'Etat n'a pas à prendre parti
pour une proposition de reprise ou
pour une autre.
En revanche, je veux être clair
sur les deux points d'attention
qui seront les nôtres: le premier
est la solidité du projet
industriel.
Casino est un groupe solide, avec
des actifs répartis à travers tout
le territoire, avec des salariés
qui font un travail formidable,
qui n'ont pas à payer pour les
erreurs qui ont pu être commises
par la direction du groupe.
Nous serons attentifs à la
solidité du projet industriel des
deux repreneurs.
Le deuxième sujet sur lequel nous
serons attentifs, c'est l'avenir
des 50.000 salariés du groupe,
répartis sur tout le territoire,
et l'avenir des 1500 salariés du
groupe à Saint-Etienne.
Il n'est pas question que le siège
historique du groupe soit menacé
par la reprise du groupe, quel que
soit le repreneur qui sera choisi
à l'issue de ce processus.
Il y a donc un soutien de l'Etat
par le report de charges et de
propositions solides sur la table.
L'Etat sera vigilant sur l'emploi
et sur le siège de Saint-Etienne
auquel je sais que vous êtes très
attaché.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Annick
Cousin.
- Annick Cousin: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Un rapport de la Cour des comptes
publié hier met en évidence une
fois encore les dérives concernant
le recours au cabinet de conseil
durant la gouvernance d'Emmanuel
Macron.
Le recours à ces cabinets de
conseil privés, parfois étrangers,
a considérablement augmenté au
cours des 10 dernières années,
passant de 11 millions d'euros en
2014 à 103 millions en 2018 pour
atteindre 200 millions en 2022.
Ces chiffres n'incluent pas les
prestations dans le domaine
informatique qui sont, elles,
parfois utiles.
Je parle de dépenses plus
contestables.
Une telle intrusion du secteur
privé dans la gestion des affaires
publiques soulève des
interrogations.
Une question de transparence, de
prévention des conflits d'intérêts
d'abord, une question de confiance
en notre haute administration
ensuite.
Les missions demandées sont
souvent identiques à celles
opérées
mais il y a enfin une question de
maîtrise de la dépense de l'argent
public de la part d'un
gouvernement qui se prétend bon
gestionnaire.
Comment justifier un paiement à
prix d'or d'une étude visant "à
réfléchir à l'évolution du métier
d'enseignant" ou à "réorganiser
l'enseignement scolaire"?
Nos enseignants ne sont-ils pas
compétents pour réfléchir à leur
métier?
Nos fonctionnaires non plus?
Nous avons une haute
administration parmi la plus
réputée du monde.
Pourquoi une telle défiance à
l'égard de la haute fonction
publique française?
Comment justifiez-vous cela?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci pour la
parole est à monsieur Stanislas
Guerini.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci.
Madame la députée Annick Cousin,
votre question, au fond, et le lot
de démagogie qui l'accompagne, ne
me surprend guère de la part de
votre famille politique.
Ce qui vous intéresse, ce sont
plus les polémiques, les problèmes
que ce que nous apportons comme
solutions.
Puisque vous m'avez interrogé, au
fond, sur la question de la
réinternalisation des compétences,
qui est effectivement une question
stratégique que j'ai toujours
regardée en face, je vais vous
répondre.
Est-ce que c'est indigne en soi
que le gouvernement puisse
recourir à une prestation de
conseil externe?
Evidemment que non!
Quand nous devons réfléchir à des
sujets structurants, qui
requièrent des compétences
extrêmement pointues, ce n'est pas
une réponse démagogique que de
dire cela, cela peut se justifier.
Est-ce que ce gouvernement agit
résolument pour réinternaliser les
compétences?
La réponse est oui, et nous le
faisons.
Si vous faisiez votre travail de
parlementaire, vous pourriez
vérifier cela.
Le budget est à destination de
tous les parlementaires.
Nous avons réinternalisé 15 postes
au sein de la Transformation
publique dès 2022.
Mais cela ne vous intéresse pas.
Nous allons continuer cette
trajectoire.
20 postes supplémentaires pour
l'année 2023.
Faites votre travail parlementaire
et vous le verrez: nous
progressons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Annick Cousin: Vos cabinets de
conseil, monsieur le ministre,
coûtent un pognon de dingue et ce
sont toujours les Français qui
payent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Emmanuel
Fernandes.
- Emmanuel Fernandes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie Bruno Le Maire qui
disait d'Emmanuel Macron, avant un
spectaculaire retournement de
veste, sport collectif en
Macronie, qu'il était "l'homme
sans projet et sans conviction".
Si, il a un projet que vous mettez
en oeuvre avec brio: enrichir les
plus riches.
La fortune cumulée des 500
Français les plus riches s'élève
désormais à 170 milliards d'euros,
soit 45% du PIB.
Un record!
Vous ne rêvez pas: les 500 plus
riches possèdent l'équivalent de
près de la moitié des richesses
produites par l'ensemble du pays
en une année.
C'était "seulement", si l'on peut
dire, 25% à l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron au pouvoir.
Une vraie success story pour le
bien nommé "président des riches".
Mais comme le disait Victor Hugo,
c'est de l'enfer des pauvres que
naît le paradis des riches.
Les mêmes pages économiques
indiquent que, depuis janvier
2022, le volume des dépenses
alimentaires a chuté de 17% dans
le pays en raison de l'inflation,
du jamais vu depuis 1980.
Une part croissante de la
population n'a plus les moyens de
se nourrir suffisamment.
Or, dans une note de l'institut La
Boétie parue hier, on apprend que
70% de la hausse des prix
alimentaires est due aux bénéfices
des groupes agroalimentaires qui
ont profité de la guerre en
Ukraine pour faire accepter des
hausses injustifiées, ainsi qu'à
la grande distribution, qui a
augmenté ses marges sur des
produits de première nécessité
tout en versant toujours plus de
dividendes.
On retrouve, surprise, les
actionnaires de ces entreprises
dans les 500 plus grandes
fortunes.
Plutôt que d'organiser la famine
pour gaver vos amis, quand
partagerez-vous enfin les
richesses?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
J'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention, monsieur le député.
Ce n'est pas facile, en deux
minutes, de répondre à la fois aux
dividendes, aux profits, à la
précarité alimentaire...
Si tant est que la réponse vous
intéresse!
Je vais essayer de répondre.
J'ai le sentiment d'avoir un beau
pot-au-feu.
C'est sympa, ça mélange des choses
qui n'ont rien à voir.
Je vais déjà vous répondre sur
l'inflation alimentaire.
Si tant est que la réponse vous
intéresse!
Sinon, ne perdons pas notre temps.
L'inflation alimentaire est en
baisse, si ça vous intéresse!
baisse.
Elle est aujourd'hui à -14%.
Je vous rappelle que, dans cette
poussée inflationniste, la France
s'en est plutôt bien sortie.
Il faut regarder ce qu'il se passe
en Espagne, en Allemagne, ce qu'il
se passe sur des mesures, si tant
est que la réponse vous
intéresse...
L'inflation en Espagne demeure
très élevée par rapport à des
propositions qui ont été mises en
place.
Vous avez proposé le blocage des
prix.
Sur l'inflation alimentaire,
cela ne marche pas.
Cela crée de la précarité et cela
ne permet pas aux plus fragiles de
s'en sortir.
Plutôt que de pérorer, en réalité,
ce qui est important...
Madame la présidente Panot?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît.
Laissez madame Olivia Grégoire
répondre.
- Olivia Grégoire: Si cela vous
intéresse, vous aurez un point sur
les prix qui ont baissé.
Pendant que vous papotez et que
vous faites votre notoriété sur la
fragilité des gens, nous
travaillons.
L'inflation alimentaire baisse et
notre pays n'a pas à en rougir.
On a accompagné les personnes les
plus fragiles pendant la crise.
Plutôt que de faire du beurre
avec, nous les accompagnons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance est suspendue.